nous poursuivons le 7-8 de cette édition
du 4 septembre en direct si vous nous
suivez entre 18 et 19 heures nous
parlons à présent rapport à vos après
avoir évoqué longuement la rentrée
scolaire avec le recteur nous allons
parler maintenant elle du bilan de la
base de loisirs la base de loisirs
régionale située sur trappe sur saint
quentin en yvelines l'été a été
difficile avec des bagarres entre bandes
rivales fin août la noyade d'un enfant
de 5 ans également
c'est à la piscine à vagues mi juillet
quelles sont les conséquences pour la
fréquentation
et puis peut-être sur la réputation tout
simplement de cette base de loisirs sur
le plateau nous rosso à présent bernard
tabary bonsoir vous êtes le président de
cette base de loisirs et frédéric bort
dit bonsoir à vous vous en êtes le
directeur je me tourne président tout
d'abord pour revenir sur ce fait divers
tragique forcément la noyade d'un enfant
sur la piscine à vagues c'était mi
juillet un enfant de 5 ans qui a échappé
à la vigilance de sa maman qui était
présente
comment s'est déroulé cet événement
comment c'est survenu comment ça peut
tout simplement survenir dans un
établissement surveiller un
établissement tout à fait surveiller
avec des règles de surveillance que nous
que nous débordons même dans la mesure
où nous faisons plus que ce que nous
impose la réglementation et pourtant
effectivement l'attention des parents
peut être prise en défaut et c'est ce
qui s'est passé là avec une maman qui
avait à sa charge 300 francs sur cet
après-midi-là est effectivement un des
trois a échappé à sa surveillance
quand ça a été un événement tout à fait
dramatique l' enquête a montré que ni
l'équipement kiss-in nino avec de
fonctionnement le sont en cause
ce brillant et par an suffisant pour
accueillir toutes les personnes qui
étaient présentes ce jour tout à fait
tout à fait et les mesures que nous
avons prises depuis justement consiste à
renforcer l'information des parents
puisque effectivement dans ce cadre là
puisqu'il s'agissait d'un déplacement
d'un centre social dans ce cadre là les
enfants sont sous la responsabilité des
parents comme au bord de la mer lorsque
vous repartez avec vos enfants
ce genre d'événements tragiques n'était
jamais arrivé à la base de loisirs ça
n'était jamais arrivé 6 milliards il ya
15 ou 20 ans je crois mais depuis depuis
cette période là rien ne s'était passé
de telle sorte ce fait divers tragique
forcément entraîné la fermeture de la
piscine à vagues pendant quelques jours
est-ce que ça a une incidence sur la
fréquentation a fermé le jour même bien
entendu et le lendemain mais très
rapidement le commissaire de police le
procureur de la république de nous a
autorisés à réouvrir sans difficulté
donc nous avons pu poursuivre l'activité
de la piscine tout l'été avec la
contrainte de la météo qui a été là
malgré tout assez pesante mais nous
avons bien fonctionné malgré tout on va
revenir justement sur les chiffres un
petit peu de cette fréquentation est
déjà sur le fait divers est ce que ça a
une incidence sur le peut-être la
réputation de la base est ce que des
gens 66 mois rassurer même si vous nous
l'avez dit à une enquête à la base
navale et le personnel n'a pas été mis
en défaut mais il n'empêche que dans les
faits il ya eu cette moyenne est ce que
ça a une incidence non il ya tout il ya
toujours forcément une inquiétude
générale qui ce qui se sent le premier
jour mais vite la vie reprend bien
entendu le pas par contre ça a une
incidence forcément sur le personnel qui
était choqué qu'un donc cellule
psychologique
on a mis des mesures en place on a aussi
on entend de travailler sur des de la
médiation sociale aussi à l'intérieur de
la base de loisirs pour encore informer
encore plus
les usagers une démarche pédagogique
envers les familles et les particuliers
on quitte la piscine à vagues pour
sortir un petit peu mais rester dans
cette base de loisirs fin aux
affrontements entre bandes rivales
problèmes de sécurité sur la base de
loisirs pour un problème de sécurité
n'ont eux pas plus que qu'ailleurs
l'ancien idole est un cas isolé
c'est complètement ce que vous réunissez
500 milles 1 million de visiteurs en
deux mois
vous avez fatalement un certain nombre
d'incivilités hélas comme partout dans
notre société et nous nous y faisons
face le mieux possible nous sommes en
parfaite coordination là aussi avec les
services de police qui s'est passé
d'ailleurs pour le petit fait que vous
vous rappelez et voilà ça arrive de
temps en temps pour autant il faut pas
que ça fasse oublier les encore une fois
les millions de visiteurs qu'ils
arrêtent de se défendre
365 4 à 64 jours par an il ya aucun
problème et on a eu un petit événement
entre quand vous dites bandes rivales
ces quatre personnes d'un côté et quatre
personnes de l'autre et ça s'est réglé
en quelques en quelques minutes la
police a réagi très très vite et ça
s'est réglé à l'extérieur de la base
vous nous citer les chais de
fréquentation presque rotation par dans
plusieurs millions de personnes sur
toute une année combien de personnes cet
été sont venus sur cette masse de jeunes
alors qu'on n'a pas le compte
on a pas le compte précis d'autant qu'on
ne peut même pas compter puisque
l'entrée piétonne
vivez-vous est libre donc avec les
empêche pas de comptage on est content
que les entrées des véhicules
effectivement donc en matière d'entrées
véhicule je crois qu'on est à peu près
l'équivalent de 2,2 l'an dernier ce qui
est moins que les très belles âmes n'est
bien entendu pour l'instant mais
globalement je pense qu'on va vers une
saison moyenne
c'est en moyenne qui va pas pour autant
mettre en difficulté financière la base
de loisirs avec les investissements qui
ont été faits aussi sur la piscine par
exemple avec les investissements bien
entendu mais bon en matière
d'investissement c'est la région vous le
savez qu'ils financent nos équipements
en revanche en matière de fonctionnement
nous nous avons un déficit chaque année
qui est couvert à parts égales par la
communauté d'agglomération et le
département et ce déficit correspond à
ce que nous appelons la mission sociale
de la base de loisirs accueillir une
fois de plus des centaines de milliers
de gens dans un parc de 600 ha ça coûte
de l'argent
entretenir une ferme pédagogique qui n'a
pas vocation à être rentable ça coûte de
l'argent
donc on a là une mission sociale qu'il
faut bien assumer par le finances
publiques
quel était le plus grand succès de la
base de loisirs cet été peut-être pour
mener maintenant il y en a plusieurs
on a un village de sportifs à
l'initiative de là
de la région avec deux mille 2000 jeunes
de 1500 jeunes à peu près on a du cinéma
de plein air on a le cros ziff avec une
opération appelée sauv'nage ou de 400
jeunes on a eu la fête des centres de
loisirs avec 1000 milles enfants voilà
on a énormément d'événements autour de 5
6000 7000 personnes sur des événements
de basses qu'on réjouit et la population
saint quentinois je voudrais c'est juste
50 12 rue de saint quentin vous voulez
c'est juste la possibilité de conclure
peut-être en nous donnant envie sur la
suite sur le programme les rendez vous à
venir je vais juste donner le programme
de la suite du 7 8 dans un instant il y
aura la chronique innovation avec maxime
le men on parlera de réalité augmentée
en piscine et puis à suivre également le
point sur les travaux dans les cinémas
de trappes et d'elancourt les cinémas de
quartier n'ont pas dit leur dernier mot
face aux multiplexes vous le verrez
c'est une petite révolution qui s'y
préparent vous avez le temps de
rassembler vos notes de réfléchir quel
est l'événement ne pas manquer pour la
rentrée le 22 et 23 septembre une grande
week end il ya une multitude
d'événements ce week-end là avec une
opération toujours à l'initiative de la
région qui s'appelle sentez vous sport
en fête pour pour résumer ces deux des
quantités de stands liés au sport on a
de la marche nordique on aura la vague
de surf on aura du tir à l'arc heures de
radio on aura énormément de d'événements
sportifs on à l'ekiden d'ekiden dévoilé
voilà on aura la journée nationale du
cheval calèche balade
à cheval en poney et puis on aura la 10e
édition de la coupe nationale de voile
entreprises grand exemple les armes
événements mais ça fait 4 4 événements
il ya vraiment michael ii du 22 et 23
septembre
merci à tous d'être venus parler bien
sûr des projets de la base de loisirs et
puis faire revenir un petit peu sur cet
été qui a été malgré tout assez
difficile du côté de la base de loisirs
en tout cas sur le plan sur le plan
humain bien sûr merci à tous les deux
filières dans le 7-8 nous évoquions les
chances de médailles des yvelinois aux
jo paralympiques à londres et notamment
l les chances de nantenin keita sous les
couleurs de l'entente athlétique de
saint quentin en yvelines elle termine
et hier soir donc lundi au pied du
podium sur le 400 mètres réservé ou
malvoyantes une grande déception pour
celle qui avait décroché le bronze sur
la même distance à pékin en 2008
nantenin keita participera également au
200 m dès ce mercredi
demain donc les communes célèbrent leur
libération à la verrière nos équipes ont
rencontré jean pietri il était témoin
des derniers combats lors de la seconde
guerre mondiale
nous sommes le 23 août 1944 trois
soldats français trouvent la mort face
aux troupes allemandes à la verrière
deux jours avant la libération cet homme
était au premier rang au volant d'une
des types du peloton de reconnaissance
comme peloton de reconnaissance il
fallait aller se faire tirer dessus pour
savoir d'où partaient les coûts
ce qu'on a fait notre le premier peloton
et vestee à voisins bretons noise a eu
un combat voisins-le-bretonneux et nous
nous sommes venus ici est nommé chambre
s'est allumée qu'on disait com publie
dans notre jargon
deux jours plus tard le régiment rallier
la porte de saint cloud sous les
acclamations
jean pietri en garde un souvenir
contrasté d'ici un souvenir de deux
tristes c'était vraiment triste de voir
la façon dont on on a été détruit à
genoux de paris non je ne lis pas que
c'était oublié mais presque
on a traversé versailles ou le décrit
des bouquets de fleurs et des bees 1 des
demoiselles et des dames
cette commémoration est organisée chaque
année par les communes du
mesnil-saint-denis de coignard et de la
verrière ainsi que par l'amicale des
anciens combattants de ces trois villes